personnes valides ou à mobilité réduite
ils étaient tous réunis pour une longue
balle géante à bois d'arcy un moyen de
s'amuser pour la bonne cause
les fonds récoltés serviront à financer
l'équipement de deux personnes
handicapées là aujourd'hui on est là
pour deux personnes
quai paul un petit garçon de huit ans
pour lui acheter un vélo électrique pour
continuer à faire du vélo avec ses
frères et soeurs et puis un garçon qui
s'appelle teddy qui a 27 ans ses parents
ont besoin d'un véhicule pour aller le
chercher au centre et comme c'est des
personnes âgées ils ont du mal à
financer leurs véhicules une dizaine de
professeurs ont encadré les différentes
sessions en fauteuil roulant ou atteints
de maladies physiques
rien n'a empêché des élèves de se
dépenser c'est ce qu'a voulu montrer
l'association un geste en plus avec
cette première édition
bah c'est pas parce qu'on est en
fauteuil roulant qu'on peut pas faire
comme les autres
en fait on a tendance à trop nous
système va nous mettre à part alors que
on a des enfants qui ont envie de faire
exactement les mêmes choses que les
autres dansent et chantent et faire du
sport s'amuser et on veut plus voir le
handicap comme quelque chose de triste
on le voir quelque chose de
joyeux et s'amuser comme les autres
bah c'était bien les gestes surtout avec
les bras basé sur les bras la tête les
épaules pas les jantes juste les bras le
long du corps c était génial je vais en
refaire une autre voie cette année
l'événement a accueilli plus d'une
centaine de participants
l'association espère pouvoir reverser
1500 euros à paul été dit une nouvelle
édition devrait avoir lieu l'an prochain